hello everyone my name is bradley and
today we're going to be talking about
fingerprints but not the ones on your
fingertips rather the fingerprints that
you leave
behind actually those that your device
leaves behind all over the internet
and it's precisely these so-called
device fingerprints that are often
weaponized by scammers and online
criminals to do
bad things
[Music]
if you're watching this you're probably
old enough to remember the first
smartphones right
now one of the biggest problems with
these old smartphones was that they'd
get quite greasy
from constant use so we'd end up using
special phone cases or screen protectors
to keep our devices clean
but luckily smartphones nowadays have
special grease resistant surfaces which
you might not know
so while our physical fingerprints no
longer stay in our phone screens
our devices can still leave digital
fingerprints all over the internet
so a device's fingerprint is effectively
its unique
digital identifier now my fingerprints
are made out of hundreds of different
papillary ridges right
but device fingerprints on the other
hand consist of hundreds of data points
and these could be things such as the
operating system that the device uses
serial numbers applications the
different settings and so on
now based on these parameters you can
actually identify
any individual device device
fingerprinting is actually
pretty common practice across hundreds
of thousands of different websites
and according to the new york times 3.5
percent of popular websites
do exactly this and that figure is
obviously steadily increasing so
how does this all work
so to access a particular website your
browser needs to provide certain
information
about your device to that website for
instance this could be information about
your screen size
and the website effectively needs that
so that it can open
the correct website format and there are
hundreds of other parameters just like
this
now individually they're not
particularly unique right but
when you add them all together you
really get something truly unique
a device fingerprint so to speak in
order to connect to the web
it'll come as no surprise that every
device needs to have an ip address
any website we open will subsequently be
able to see our address
and they can actually tell where we are
based on it
now sometimes they can only tell the
country you're in right but other times
they can actually pinpoint
your exact location and that's all done
through the ipa address
but the thing is our devices connect to
the internet
through what's known as an intermediary
right or in other words a sort of
operator network
this then connects to the internet so
even though each computer
has its own unique address when you're
surfing the web you'll actually be
identified by this
intermediary network address rather than
that of your device
now you can think about this like trying
to get through to a large company
there's of course
one main number but that number actually
corresponds to thousands of different
lines right but if you need to reach a
particular line then you'd need to dial
the extension
so you can think of the main number as
the operator network right but your
device
is more like the extension don't answer
that call just transfer the damn goal
your call is very important to us please
[Applause]
so if you happen to visit the same
website from the same device from
different locations this would actually
be reflected in your ip address since
you're actually going through different
networks now how about you go try this
yourself go on
what is my ip address and they'll tell
you where you're located simply based on
your ip
i should actually note that device
fingerprinting has implications that go
well beyond detecting your location
websites can actually use device
fingerprinting to adjust their content
based on demographics wants or needs and
interests
for example if you enter an online store
let's say sort of
harrods.com from a wealthy area well
that website will actually
show you its most expensive items first
which is
quite mad you were correct it's fact
we will access the internet using
different devices right this could be
a smartphone or it could be a smart tv
and these devices don't just differ in
terms of
their sizes they actually have different
operating systems different browsers
language settings and so on right
and websites they track all of this
information
now once you add up all of these
individual factors it's hard to imagine
having the same device fingerprint as
the next guy
now of course it's theoretically
possible but highly unlikely
accordingly the more parameters you have
the more unique your device fingerprint
will actually become
now do you want to see how unique you
are well check out this website
now its database contains over three
million digital fingerprints from
a variety of different devices and if
you go through the list of parameters
you'll see how many users
share the same browser language settings
and so on
you see all it took was for me to add a
new weird font
and my uniqueness actually went up
significantly
now my uniqueness also has a lot to do
with my browser
and i'm going to do the same test but
i'm going to use a different browser
take a look at these abstract images
this is one of the more
advanced technologies for determining a
particular browser
basically when you use a browser it
draws a small picture
and this picture actually reflects the
browser that you use
and thanks to this data the probability
that your device fingerprint actually
matches someone else's
is actually one in 286 thousand seven
hundred and seventy seven
so let's talk about cookies now cookies
were effectively
small packets of data that websites
actually saved your computer
and i'm sure that once or twice you've
clicked on the allow cookies
icon when browsing the internet right
but have you ever actually thought about
what this means for your privacy
well yes there are many benefits to
using cookies
and they do indeed help websites to
function better for instance they can
save information that makes the user
experience much more
smooth and personal like your personal
search settings or even your login
information right
but the bad news is that cookie files
can be easily compromised by bad actors
especially when one doesn't have an
encrypted internet connection
now this risk increases particularly
when using public wi-fi
at your local cafe for instance in
essence cookies have
severe implications for your privacy
when browsing the web
and that's why many browsers actually
offer a service that blocks the cookies
altogether
but doing so means that certain websites
actually won't function at all
now one thing i do suggest is to allow
cookies but regularly delete them from
your computer say at least once a week
and don't do this through your browser
do it actually manually or with a
dedicated program
now there is another way to uniquely
identify your device and this is through
tracking the websites that you visit
now if someone knows which popular
websites i do or
don't visit they'll actually have a 90
chance of successfully identifying me
now websites don't have the ability to
see my browsing history but well
i mean you know you can tell when you
visited a link just by
the color of it right so it goes from
blue to purple well
some sneaky types actually figured out
how to use this
against us to figure out where i've been
bad actors compile long lists of links
to particular websites and
if i visit one of these links they'll
actually change the color
to purple now what they're doing here
isn't actually that
difficult on the one hand they can't
exactly detect your
entire internet history through this
method but still by analyzing
the most popular 50 websites they're
still getting half the way there right
now the technical information links to
our devices is a whole other story
yes i mean i could distort this
information by changing my operating
system or
blocking cookies ip blockers and so
forth and
that's not really hard to do but what's
more difficult it's actually changing
the physical characteristics of my
devices
now let's come back to i am unique.org
now you can see here that there's
actually data on audio systems
used by the devices like speakers and
microphones for instance
so if i were to connect some kind of
audio device to my macbook
like a bluetooth speaker for instance
the uniqueness of this device actually
increases considerably but look guys
disconnecting a speaker from your device
is no big deal
really yes but what if someone could
figure out the specifics
of the chip inside of your phone for
instance after all this is a component
that you really can't change
and this was actually an issue that
browser developers saw beforehand
so they've actually taken measures to
prevent the primary specs of your device
from being accessed
but this is not to say that there aren't
certain exceptions to this
now in may of 2019 a group of
researchers from cambridge published a
study about
a unique device fingerprint that was
developed through the use of an imu
sensor
now these are effectively microscopic
chips that allow smartphones to
determine their whereabouts and physical
positions within the world right
now these sensors are extremely
sensitive and each of them contain data
that is truly unique
so how can an imu sensor be accessed
through a browser
when browsers do so much to prevent this
from even happening in the first place
well have you ever noticed how websites
rotate together with your phone screen
well that's actually done through a
direct line of communication between the
browser
and the imu sensor now this is just one
method but there are actually dozens of
other ways to determine a truly unique
device fingerprint
and obviously for time constraints i
can't get into all of them today
now how would you like to hear about how
to take control
of your device fingerprint now you can
enjoy a little more privacy in your life
[Music]
well the idea here is to simplify your
fingerprint as much as possible by
reducing the amount of
identifiable information that you
provide but you don't need to
restore your phone to factory settings
to do so right you can actually just
install
a second operating system on your device
and effectively keep it completely
unchanged
don't add any weird fonts and certainly
don't delete any of the native ones for
instance
then you need to download a safe browser
and
don't add anything on that either no
plugins
language selectors or anything like that
i mean all of that can actually lead to
identifiable information being collected
from you
i would probably disable cookies
javascript flash and web
gl to start and obviously it goes
without saying when accessing the
internet
always use a vpn connection this will
help you to
hide your ip address now there are
actually thousands of services out there
and some are actually free to use so
give it a google
now this is kind of similar to putting a
pair of gloves
on before you commit a robbery and
because of this
you'll leave a less identifiable trace
of yourself
is this a bit too radical for you though
well i mean here's a simpler approach
you can simply download firefox and
install a plugin
that purposefully provides false
information about your device
now i like to use the agent switcher but
there are plenty of different
alternatives you'll find
on the internet in the plugin settings
you'll need to make sure that your
uniqueness is as low as possible the
similarity ratio should be green
on am i unique.org now this could be
a real pain but it's really worth the
effort for privacy right
but this method makes me think about how
criminals could technically pose as
someone else right just by simulating
another device's fingerprint
now in the online jungle this really is
a possibility in february of 2019
cyber security experts discovered a
website that was selling 60
000 device fingerprints that's right 60
000. and this is a store where you could
literally purchase someone else's
digital identity
and use it for malicious intent now
think about it your iphone's device
fingerprint could have been listed for
sale on that website
now you maybe didn't even know that your
device had one of these fingerprints yep
it's there
up for sale on the dark web now these
tended to cost between five and two
hundred dollars each the price obviously
depends how dense the information
is and using these stolen identities
criminals can actually
fall banks and circumvent certain
anti-fraud systems
so how does this all work well when you
enter your bank card information in an
online store
the smoking system carefully analyzes
the quest and does two things
first of all it checks whether the
information is correct and then
it checks whether device fingerprint
coincides with the ones that you've used
in the past
now if the data here more or less
matches it permits the transaction
now obviously when you have someone
else's device fingerprint
it's much easier to bypass these types
of security systems
now a good question here is can you
protect your device fingerprint from
being stolen
and sold on the dark web yes
you can and the easiest way to make your
device fingerprint unappealing to bad
actors is by making it as
generic as possible the less unique your
device fingerprints is the less likely
it will be of interest anyone on the
dark web
so do you occupy yourself with hiding
your device fingerprint completely or do
you just relax
live and let it go well it's honestly a
tough question especially for me but
my aim is not only to the technologies
that are destroying our privacy but also
to warn you
about the dangers that are lurking in
every corner of the internet
and that also some of these dangers can
stem from something as ordinary as the
device that you hold in your hand
so look thanks for watching and by the
way if you've got any other ideas for
another video that we could do please
please drop us a comment
as a lot of you already know i'm reading
meticulously every single one of the
comments if you want to connect with me
or
share an idea that's burning in your
mind please please do comment because
i'll definitely see it and share it with
our wonderful team here
otherwise thank you for accompanying me
on this excursion through the online
jungle i'm bradley and this is some sub
see you in the next video
[Music]
you